bonjour à vous les syndicats qui sont
donc reçu aujourd'hui par le ministre de
l'intérieur vous attendait des actes et
non plus des déclarations d'amour est ce
que vous avez le sentiment que vous
allez les avoir ces preuves d'amour de
la part du ministre oui c'est amusant la
sémantique que vous utilisez des preuves
d'amour je crois qu'effectivement il
faut il faut craindre que cette
réception des syndicats ne ressemble à
une calinothérapie évidente est utile
dans un dans un contexte très
particulier pour ne pas dire explosif
jamais on a assisté à une telle remise
en cause de l'institution police dans ce
pays et il ya vraiment péril en la
demeure
si cette situation perdure en ce qui
tombe bien parce que beaucoup de des
interlocuteurs que vous avez interrogé
parle de budget ça tombe bien puisque le
ministre de l'intérieur et l'ancien
ministre du budget donc il sait de quoi
il parle et il s'est surtout il connaît
surtout quelle est sa marge de manoeuvre
dans le cadre de ces de ces négociations
qui s'annoncent donc n'aura pas l'excusé
de ne pas savoir ce qui se passe de
l'autre côté de la barrière
ce qui me gêne un petit peu et la cram
que beaucoup de policiers de terrain on
sait qu'on tombe justement dans le piège
d'une discussion qui ne tourne qu sujet
qu autour de sujets corporatistes et
uniquement matériels le mot de sens du
métier a été utilisé mais j'ai envie de
rajouter d'en rajouter une couche en
disant que si on s'écarte du débat
essentiel qui consiste à se poser la
question de savoir quelle est la place
de la police dans notre société et
qu'elle sera t-elle dans le dans le
monde de demain dans le monde futur dont
on nous parle sans arrêt on passe à côté
du sujet tous les débats de mon point de
vue est de plus de conduite beaucoup
tous les débats qui ne tiennent pas
compte ou qui ne se pose pas la question
de savoir quelle sera la place de
l'institution police dans dans la norme
dans la notion de service public de ce
pays est nulle et non avenue
il ya un triptyque essentiel à côté
duquel on ne peut pas passer c'est celui
des trois piliers de la notion de
service public et de l'état globalement
celui de la sécurité qui englobe la
police et la justice celui de
l'enseignement et de la santé
nous avons les mêmes problèmes ces trois
institutions ont les mêmes problèmes à
savoir quelle est la vision globale du
service public actuellement dans ce pays
et qu'il est la réflexion qui va en
débouchés qui va déboucher sur l'étang
fuite
si on nous parle que des bidons et des
gamelles ça ne servira strictement à
rien il y à un débat de fond à mener sur
cette thématique de la place de la
police est globalement du service public
il faut surtout pas se cantonner de
débats corporatiste ce serait dangereux
de mon point de vue justement je perds
quand l'anglais ce qu'est ce qu'elles
sont vos attentes précisément on a
entendu que vous souhaitiez une refonte
du système c'est d'ailleurs souvent vous
avez raison de comparer sa au débat sur
l'hôpital parce que c'est souvent ce
qu'on reproche il ya certains qui
demandent des moyens mais mais d'autres
qui disent maintenant il faut refonder
tout ce système vous semblez dire la
même chose pour la police quelles sont
vos attentes dans ce domaine quelles
doivent être les grands axes de
changement mais complètement il faut un
débat de fond et pas simplement un débat
catégorielles et un débat d'ailleurs les
syndicats sont reçus les uns après les
autres
est-ce que ça débouchera sur une vision
globale j'en doute puisque chacun risque
de défendre son pré carré et ce serait
ça c'est catastrophique
il y à une demande de certains pas de
tout le monde mais de certains à revoir
effectivement l'institution dans sa
globalité sur les formes de recrutement
de formation et de cohésion avec et de
dialogue avec les institutions qui sont
partenaires comme la justice notamment
si on passe à côté de tout ça sanaa ça
ne servira strictement à rien je le
répète il n'ya pas que des questions de
fournitures il ya aussi ce qu'on va en
faire et quel est le sens des missions
qui seront alloués à la police nationale
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
globale ça nécessitera autre chose que
des entrevues de ce type ne perdons pas
de vue non plus que monsieur darmanin
qui a probablement toutes les qualités a
un contrat à durée très déterminée au
sein de ce gouvernement
on va dire au maximum qui sera d'un an
et demi quelles sont les réformes qui
pourra réellement envisagé de mettre en
place
je doute que ça puisse s'inscrire dans
la durée donc au delà du dialogue qui
consistera à dire on vous aime beaucoup
vous êtes les piliers de la nation ça
c'est très bien mais il faut revenir
vraiment vraiment des problèmes il faut
les mettre sur la table et pas se
contenter d évoquer de manière très
succincte très très superficielle le
débat de la relation entre la justice et
la police y est essentielle en ce moment
on voit bien qu'on traverse une crise
comme on n'en a jamais connue en un mois
on vient de voir trois meurtres qui sont
d'une sauvagerie mais hallucinante
la gendarme a été assassiné a été tuée
par un chauffard qui roulait à 130 kg
truer un chauffeur de bus s'est vu
massacrés par des barbares littéralement
sur son lieu de travail dans des
conditions qu'il faut imaginer
on ne peut pas tuer quelqu'un à coups de
poing comme ça c'est il faut vraiment
avoir en tête des images qui sont très
probablement sordide mais qu'il faut
avoir à l'esprit est là récemment on
vient de voir qu'un drame s'est passé à
lyon dans des conditions mais
surréaliste il faut une réponse pénale
n'est pas simplement une action
policière
c'est ça c'est pour ça que je répète je
dis je répète et tant pis si je ressasse
un peu mais il faut un débat de fond
véritablement on a voilà on nous entende
on a l'impression que vous êtes plutôt
voilà ouvert et vous accueillez plutôt
bien le nouveau ministre il n'empêche ce
n'est pas le cas des féministes vous le
savez il ya une plainte pour viol qui
vise gérald darmanin ça complique sa
mission selon vous la justice doit
suivre son cours et ça n'a rien à voir
avec la fonction si vous le permettez je
mets un petit bémol j'accueille veut
bien la venue de ce nouveau ministre on
le connaît pas ce parti on parle que de
la fonction dont on verra bien après
l'opportunité de l'avoir nommé à ce
poste c'est pas à moi d'en juger
responsabilité en incombe aux politiques
qu'ils auront à débattre là dessus et
éventuellement à la justice donc un
satisfecit sur monsieur darmanin
certainement pas en tout cas il est
beaucoup trop tôt pour le pour le dire
seules les actions comme l'on dit des
collègues syndicalistes
seules les actions qu'il mènera seront
déterminantes pour juger la qualité de
son action mais on a été trop longtemps
habitués à des ministres qui étaient
plus dans l'agitation dans la posture
plutôt que dans l'action
il vous a pas échappé qu'on a une vision
du service public est purement comptable
les mouvements de l'hôpital ou
mouvements du monde hospitalier le
démontre il faut il faudrait
véritablement d'ailleurs un sujet c'est
parce qu'un appel que je lance mais qui
une solidarité de relations entre le
monde le monde médical et le monde de la
police qui connaît exactement le même
problème ce sont les mêmes
préoccupations puisque ces deux
institutions depuis une vingtaine
d'années à peu près sûr gouverner sous
les tic purement budgétaires et
comptables et ça n'est pas possible ce
sont des métiers qui sont profondément
humains
si on fait l'impasse sur tout ça on est
cette année chaque année c'est tout
simplement merci jean pierre col
anglaise d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france merci m